and speaking of recruiting
got a special guest for you here a guy
that was seriously recruited by tom
brady
zip recruiter couldn't ask for anything
better than what tom brady did
with our next guest rob gronkowski joins
us via telephone
gronk hello welcome to the world and
welcome to the match how you doing my
friend
yeah what's up guys i'm here at my
nephew's baseball game it's the first
one i've uh
i've ever caught and it's the only one i
can catch this year so
i couldn't zoom in right now but i'm
just you know lucky to be on the phone
call but let me tell you
i recruited tom to tampa he didn't
recruit me i told him that he was going
to tampa so he went to tampa
you're just on the beach hanging out tom
can you validate the story i mean you
know who called who and
man it all seemed to work out nicely it
worked out nice it was a team decision
how could i go somewhere and not bring
you know the greatest tight end in nfl
history what he's
done is unbelievable so and he's still
got more to prove so
you know what the great thing about
having him is when i make crappy throws
he just
he pulls them in just kind of like my
partner just did i just yanked one left
into the woods my partner knocks it to
12 feet so
you know i got phil mickelson as a
partner out here i got gronk as my
great friend and teammate how good is it
for me
that's the truth tom you you always
what's up tom you always have a great
supporting cast around you that
you know you're smart like that bobby g
are you are you what are you
you're not hopefully not at the beach
too much you're ready to go aren't you i
mean we're
we're get we're going here in three
weeks i know my god
we're ready i mean i'm i'm wondering if
you're ready you missed all of otas
you're out golfing now i if you haven't
seen me do anything i've been just
training getting ready catching
footballs
i'm studying my competition look i'm 30
yards away from aaron who's
you know you know that the leader of the
packers
i think uh you know so i'm gonna be i'm
just watching his mannerisms i'm
studying i'm
her recruiting a little bit just hey
you're starting the wrong guy man
aaron looks more lazy now than i did in
retirement oh
whoa i don't know if aaron's hearing all
this but feel free to check in there
aaron
talking about my quarterback what are
you saying exactly
he looks what's that he looks like he
looks focused
up close and personal he looks he's
dialed in he's going to have a good year
i know he's got tough competition coming
up
gronk how's your golf game right now you
dialed in erin's on the line i didn't
even know that oh yeah they're all
listening
they're all listening go ahead go ahead
caller let's rob
from the beach go ahead rob hey aaron
how you doing
hey buddy looking looking a little slow
out there right now
oh
you talking about my flight no bryson's
the slowest in the group trust me
all the exploring
loud and clear i just think that uh you
know it's this little uh
little jabs everybody's giving me and
you know what i think i'm going to make
this putt now
because of that brock you've been doing
a lot of calves curls cardio or what
speed it up a little bit doing a lot of
what
calves curls cardio spring break 20 22
getting ready yeah i'm like i'm always
ready that's
that's the thing i'm always ready to go
and you can go
more check it out my calves are looking
pretty good though you'll see
they'll be popping
all right rob we appreciate your time
man you're one of them
one of the best recruits ever just like
our friends at zip recruiter way to go
tom brady you guys want a super bowl
rob we we look forward to catch up with
you again get your golf game dialed in
because
we're gonna have to get you a part of
the match